When antibiotics were first introduced in 1944, they were considered a miracle cure.
They were used to treat a wide variety of diseases,...
...like tuberculosis, salmonella, and pneumonia.
Antibiotics were intended to be used sparingly to preserve their effectiveness.
Today, most of our antibiotics are fed to factory farm animals.
Antibiotics make the animals grow faster...
...and enable them to survive unhealthy conditions.
This system is creating antibiotic-resistant superbugs,...
...making us all vulnerable to diseases they once cured.
These superbugs are contaminating our soil, our water, and the very food we eat.
It doesn't have to be this way.
You have a choice, and together, we can change the system.
Support Meat Without Drugs and stop the superbugs.